les convois de la liberté en mouvement
qui divise un journaliste a même été
suspendu de la radio pour laquelle il
travaillait après avoir déclaré que le
convoi de la liberté n'est pas un
mouvement raciste les équipes de r t
internationales ont réussi à le joindre
écoutez son avis sur la situation
j'ai l'impression que les gens
soutiennent les camionneurs il ya une
gigantesque vague d'amour de soutien et
de liberté et je pense que les médias
traditionnels cash cela et ne leur donne
pas voix au chapitre et on constate une
frustration extrême chez ces canadiens
dont la voix n'est pas entendue kaling
of the world famous people
je pense que la plupart des gens
estiment que le gouvernement est allé
trop loin depuis un long moment déjà je
pense que cela contribue en fait à
éveiller l'opinion publique sur le
problème de corruption et très
franchement sur la folie du moment
au caire pourrait être bloquée pour cela
j'ai moi même fait un don aux convois de
camionneurs alors ma femme et moi on se
dit eh bien nous sommes sur cette liste
devrions-nous nous inquiéter parce qu'il
s'agit d'un excès de pouvoir du
gouvernement tellement dingue que je
pense que cela à l'effet inverse de ce
qu attendaient justin trudeau et ça ne
va pas nous faire reculer ça nous incite
en fait à nous battre encore plus fort
car les taxiways king